moi ce que je veux c'est interdire les
dsp
voilà je vais être plus clair interdire
la délégation au privé juste sur la
question démocratique c'est pas faire
venir des citoyens pour faire venir des
citoyens
je veux dire vous avez vu par exemple
désastre des partenariats public privé
dans notre dans notre pays on sait très
bien que lorsqu'on établit un contrat
avec un partenaire comme veolia suez la
saur et d'autres qu'on retrouve
d'ailleurs exactement les mêmes lorsque
l'on va de ville en ville puisque ce
sont les mêmes contrats qui sont faits
eh bien vous comprenez bien que lorsque
vous faites des contrats sur 15 20 ans
et que vous n'avez pas accès aux
informations sur quel est l'état de
votre réseau sur ou est ce que va
l'argent exactement des usagers de l'eau
et bien que c'est un vrai souci
démocratique et donc ce n'est pas à
mettre des citoyens pour faire semblant
de mettre des citoyens mais c'est avoir
une gestion démocratique et collective
pour gérer au mieux le réseau d'eau et
l'accès et le droit à l'eau à toutes et
tous il y a plus de personnes qui
meurent du fait d'un mauvais accès à une
qualité de l'eau et à l'assainissement
ou agolo de mauvaise qualité que de
personnes qui sont mortes dans le monde
du cobp id
il parlait de toutes les gaffes faut
quand même revenir sur l'ampleur de la
situation qu'on vit déjà aujourd'hui et
non ce n'est pas qu'une question de
développement parce qu'en fait plus que
la quantité même nous allons avoir un
problème de qualité de l'eau marquer
mais là un peu évoquée mais moi je veux
quand même revenir dessus
il ya vraiment un problème qui va être
extrêmement fort de qualité de la
ressource en eau notamment due à des
pollutions liées à des activités
minières agricoles bond lié aux
pesticides youn et ça et ça c'est
l'enjeu majeur de notre siècle
et pour le coup moi je pense qu'il faut
prendre très au sérieux cette question
d'eau et si je voulais rebondir sur ce
que disait marc laimé tout à l'heure en
disant l'eau est sorti de l'histoire eh
bien l'on revient aussi dans l'histoire
est allé et elle revient dans l'histoire
par les peuples parce que nous on a
notamment regardé ce qui se passait avec
les révolutions citoyennes un peu dans
le monde notamment au chili notamment en
irak dont marqué mais a parlé aussi où
toutes ces révolutions citoyennes sont
liées justement notamment à la question
de l'eau
le chili c'est un des premiers pays au
monde où l'eau a été privatisée
il se trouve que sur les dix villes où
l'eau est la plus chère en amérique
latine il y en a sept qui sont chilienne
et c'était une des raisons de la colère
populaire
[Musique]